madame monsieur bonsoir michel rocard
tire les conséquences de son échec aux
élections européennes il remet son
avenir personnel entre les mains du
parti socialiste ils devraient décider
dimanche s'il lui renouvelle sa
confiance dans l'affairé yann piat les
deux hommes jusqu'ici soupçonné du
meurtre du député du var ont été
disculpés ce soir l'un d'eux a même été
remise en liberté le rwanda la france
par la voix d'alain juppé promet
d'intervenir et d'envoyer des soldats si
les combats ne cessent pas et puis nous
évoquerons également à l'étranger le
drame du soudan où une guerre oubliée
ravage le pays depuis onze ans enfin un
hommage à la fin de ce journal
hommage à un acteur un chanteur un
peintre décédé hier soir à paris
mouloudji avait 61 ans
moi
de mou souris
mais là
la mort par des rues nous et
iran
nous retrouvons nous dit à la fin du
journal pour commencer donc cette
édition l'actualité politique michel
rocard mérite-t-il encore la confiance
des socialistes michel rocard est il
candidat naturel du parti pour la
prochaine présidentielle
après trois jours de silence radio c'est
lui même qui a posé cette double
question cet après midi devant le bureau
national du ps pour la confiance la
réponse devrait venir dimanche pour la
présidentielle d'ici la fin de l'année
un bureau national suivi cet après midi
et encore ce soir par guilaine chenu et
françois granet on n'avait pas vu depuis
trois jours on le disait décourager
sonné et le voilà aujourd'hui est-ce
qu'ils sont un sourire avant de prendre
place parmi les siens pour s'expliquer
et réagir tout ce que le parti
socialiste compte comme courant et comme
stratégie est là derrière cette vitre
intentions pures comme d'habitude ce
serait trop commode est pas la bonne
solution de dire coupant une tête et
tout ira mieux
aujourd'hui donc on n'écartera pas
michel rocard mais impossible d'éviter
la contestation car elle gronde même si
ses propres amis alors chacun ira de sa
proposition pour le parti et pour
l'homme fois elles sont vraiment de
gauche sociale ils doivent être eux
mêmes et pas avoir l'air d'hésiter sur
leur ligne politique
le moment venu nous choisirons le
meilleur des candidats pour défendre nos
couleurs aux élections présidentielles à
l'intérieur les discussions ont commencé
dans la cour on distribue la déclaration
de michel rocard
dimanche il remettra son mandat entre
les mains des militants mais ce n'est
pas tout il ya aussi la présidentielle
michel rocard a décidé que j'irai pas de
geler les fonds proviennent d'une cette
amère à la dégelée
c'est à dire de dire on en parlera le
temps venu tout le monde a le droit
d'être candidat il n'a pas dit si lui le
saurai ou pas d'ailleurs
la question n'est pas tranchée je pense
même d'ailleurs dans sa tête mais en
tout cas tout le monde ira avec ses
propositions et les militants débattront
et décideront ce soir donc le parti
socialiste n'a plus de candidat naturel
à l'élection présidentielle quant à son
premier secrétaire son sort sera décidé
dimanche prochain je propose de
retrouver roland sicard en direct de la
rue de solférino où le bureau national
se poursuit roland
la question est désormais posée est ce
que michel rocard sera encore à la tête
du parti socialiste dimanche
m'écoutais je crois qu'on peut résumer
la situation d'une façon assez simple le
scrutin de dimanche avait mis en cause
la légitimité de michel rocard michel
rocard répond en posant la question
confiance on l'a dit il remettra
dimanche son mandat de premier
secrétaire en jeu alors et bien quels
sont les rapports de force et quels sont
les intérêts en présence il ya d'abord
michel rocard lui-même son intérêt est
de conserver sa place c'est sa seule
chance de pouvoir espérer rebondir
politiquement
ensuite il ya les amis de jacques delors
eux aussi ont intérêt à ce que michel
rocard reste à sa place pourquoi
et bien parce que jacques de haller est
encore pour six mois et bruxelles son
intérêt est de conserver le statu quo et
puis il y à laurent fabius et ses amis
qui tiennent en fait la clé du problème
mais laurent fabius lui aussi a plutôt
intérêt à ce que michel rocard est à sa
place pardon pourquoi pour une raison
aussi tout à fait simple c'est que
laurent fabius ni candidat ni à
l'élection présidentielle ni au poste de
premier secrétaire autrement dit et bien
dimanche michel rocard devrait en toute
logique conserver son poste de premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste mais il
faut être prudent parce que vous le
savez la politique a souvent ses raisons
que la raison ne connaît pas merci
beaucoup roland coup de théâtre dans le
var les deux hommes qui étaient
considérés jusqu'ici comme les deux
tueurs présumés du député yann piat
assassiné au mois de mars et bien ces
deux hommes ont été mis hors de cause ce
soir un rebondissement qui coïncide avec
de nouvelles interpellations ce matin à
tout non yannick la russie agnès varda
après trois mois de détention les
premiers mots de denis labelle
blainville a remis en liberté ce soir il
reste mis en examen pour assassinat
soupçonné d'être le tireur sur la moto
ce sont ses parents qui sont venus le
chercher une libération comme l'aveu
d'un échec de tâtonnements dans l'
enquête le jour aussi où les policiers
procèdent au plus vaste coup de filet
dans cette affaire le mandat de dépôt
d'épiphanie au pericolo a aussi été
levée mais le pilote présumé de la moto
reste pour l'instant en prison car il
est mis en examen dans une autre affaire
pour avoir agressé yann piat dans un
meeting en 92 emmenés pour être
confronté avec les interpellés de ce
matin il devrait sortir rapidement son
avocat évoque son amertume l'obligation
de trouver des coupables lendemain du
crime et insiste sur la fragilité de
l'unique témoignage
n'oublions pas que pericolo labadie sont
en prison depuis quatre mois à cause
tu fait pas cause parce qu'il n'y a pas
de raison d'accuser ce témoin mais du
fait d'un témoignage
on s'aperçoit que ces témoins s'est
trompé oui j'ai trompé voilà on l'a un
peu élèves qu'on prévoit est justement
parmi les 25 personnes arrêtées ce matin
un homme qui ressemble physiquement
epifanio pericolo et que les enquêteurs
recherchaient depuis plusieurs semaines
le témoin aurait t'il confondu les deux
hommes
pour l'instant les auditions ne semble
pas avoir été à la hauteur des
espérances des enquêteurs car ceux ci
attendent de pouvoir identifier les
voleurs de la moto du crime
il disposerait de deux suspects ce matin
les policiers ont frappé dans le petit
milieu varois un patron de bar du port
de hyères soupçonné d'avoir accueilli
des complices ou même les auteurs du
crime mais aussi les jeunes toxicomanes
et parmi eux le fils du chauffeur de
yann piat rodolphe arnaud recherché et
qui s'est présenté spontanément cet
après midi aux policiers mais il faudra
attendre la fin des auditions pour
savoir si ce coup de filet est un réel
retournement fructueux dans cette
affaire la sécurité dans les lycées les
collèges a été au centre d'une
expérience peu banale aujourd'hui une
nouvelle fois en cause les bâtiments du
type pailleron qui n'offre pas des
conditions de sécurité suffisantes
il y en a mille en france est plutôt que
de les détruire une entreprise propose
un réaménagement pour prouver
l'efficacité de sa méthode
cette entreprise a fait cet après midi à
paris un test incendie dans un bâtiment
désaffecté un test suivi par claude
samper et raymond chapelet allez allez
allez hop on s'en va pousse pousse
c'est ce qu'on appelle une expérience
grandeur nature le feu vient d'être mis
volontairement une salle de classe d'un
établissement du type pailleron une
démonstration scientifique opérée par
une société privée
spécialiste en matériel incendie on
cherche à démontrer que l'ensemble du
parc existant ou la quasi totalité du
parc existantes pour ce type de bâtiment
parfaitement être réhabilité remis aux
normes de sécurité sans pour autant être
obligé de détruire
l'expérience a été préparée durant un
mois
minutieusement toutes les structures
métalliques du bâtiment à partie la plus
fragile ont été renforcées dans la
classe 300 capteurs de température
poursuivre minute après minute la
progression du feu cet après-midi en dix
minutes la température a dépassé les
1000 degrés normalement dans un
établissement du type pailleron non
protégés les structures métalliques se
seraient déjà effondré parmi la centaine
d'observateurs invités à cette
démonstration max causse lors de
l'incendié du collège pailleron le 6
février 1973 il avait perdu sa fille de
8 ans je pense que c'est un peu une
mascarade parce qu'elle qu'est ce qu'on
nous montre là on transforme une salle
de classe
on enlève tout ce qui est matériaux
combustibles ou au bep tonnes tout
autour et on met le feu bon qui a rien à
voler a rien à brûler un test incendie
un peu trop bien préparés ou une
expérience positive pour jean marie
schléret qui a répertorié tous les
bâtiments scolaires à risque en france
aucun doute
la démonstration est concluante on a
protégé la structure métallique qui as à
100° il faut le rappeler se déforme et
donc fait que le bâtiment va s'effondrer
au lieu d'avoir cette déformation 20
minutes ici en là en une heure or
l'évacuation se fait en trois minutes
il reste en france plus de 1000
établissements scolaires un risque la
sécurité de deux cent mille élèves est
en jeu faut-il les détruire ou les
renforcer c'est une question de sécurité
mais c'est aussi
archer au chapitre social la nouvelle
réduction d'effectifs annoncées hier par
le groupe michelin provoque aujourd'hui
une très vive réaction des syndicats du
fabricant de pneus ils dénoncent un
nouveau coup de force on leur répond
modernisation reportage à clermont
ferrand de valérie kg et frédéric de la
pensée des nouvelles mesures annoncées
par la direction citant les parieurs
n'ont pas encore s de la résignation de
l'indifférence ou la crainte d'une
sanction en tout cas aux portes des
usines michelin de clermont on est peu
loquace rares sont les ouvriers qui
acceptent de commenter les 727
suppressions d'emplois programmées ici
avant fin 95
pour vous est-ce que c'est un 7e plan de
licenciement pratiquement ça revient à
ça même si juridiquement on prétend que
c'est un plan d'adaptation permanente
inquiet oui parce que moi j'ai deux
enfants qui ont plus de 20 ans
aujourd'hui sont chômeurs à clermont la
direction envisage 490 départs en pré
retraite c'est sans doute ce qui
explique l'absence de réaction de la
plupart des salariés assurés concernés
manar
normalement on part en effet 2
joie l'année prochaine vous êtes
satisfait
enfin moi très peut-être pas le meilleur
chez michelin à peine 4 % des personnels
sont syndiqués même les plans sociaux à
répétition ne suffisent pas pour
mobiliser massivement les salariés en
mai comme ailleurs en une région qui est
en train de créer une ville qui est en
train de crever ce qu'on voit c'est peu
mais les emplois bon faudrait quand même
qu'ils avaient elles sont un peu plus de
compréhension de la part des salariés
devant ce phénomène
je fais il faut qu'ils réagissent parce
que ça fait dix ans qu'on a des plans et
ça fait quand même 14 suppressions
d'emplois en dix ans et si les gens ne
font rien ça continuera comme ça et le
dernier d'atteindre à la porte voix au
début des années 80 les usines michelin
de clermont comptait près de 30000
salariés à la fin 95 les effectifs
auront été réduits de plus de la moitié
toute la région doit s'adapter à la cure
d'amaigrissement du bibendum voyez
depuis 1983 c'est la septième réductions
d'effectifs donc dans le groupe michelin
edouard balladur a demandé ce matin en
conseil des ministres à françois
mitterrand la convocation d'une session
extraordinaire du parlement au mois de
juillet pour examiner le projet de loi
pasqua sur l'aménagement du territoire
il s'agit vous le savez de rééquilibrer
la france des villes et la france
deschamps mais déjà les maires de
certaines grandes villes craignent
d'être les grands oubliés de ceux de ce
projet reportage entre dunkerque et
amiens de tir et kurt et toutes
tendances confondues les maires des
grandes villes de france tire la
sonnette d'alarmé la loi en préparation
sur l'aménagement du territoire oublie
la ville où vivent trois français sur
quatre
dunkerque deux cent mille habitants
mairie socialiste
ce qui inquiète michel delebarre c'est
la réforme de la taxe professionnelle
elle est pour l'instant fixé par la
ville et représente 25 à 60% de ses
revenus
c'est donc principalement cet impôt qui
permet la restauration des quartiers
cette taxe tout le monde est d'accord
accentue les déséquilibres dans une même
agglomération
il faut la réformer mais pas n'importe
comment quand j'entends dire que la
réforme de la taxe professionnelle
pourrait faire en sorte que cette taxe
professionnelle reste pas au niveau des
villes ou des agglomérations mais
partent au niveau des départements ou du
national je crains une perte de capacité
et ça ce serait dramatique
amiens cent trente mille habitants mary
udf sur le chantier de la future
autoroute paris londres gilles de robien
montre les premières habitations
130 mètres entre ce quartier populaire
et l'ascèse l'aménagement du territoire
ici c'est d'abord une mise en
supplémentaire derrière eux le
financement du projet ne permet de
réparer cette nuisance
c'est alors la ville qui doit compenser
elle redessine le quartier elle augmente
le nombre de bus à miers se retrouver
avec les charges un bus ses 17 points 10
km alors que l'autoroute profitera à
toutes les communes de l'agglomération
je crois qu'on peut pas aménager
l'hexagone mais des autoroutes et des jv
et des trains en oubliant finalement là
où il ya le plus forte concentration de
population ça veut dire des
agglomérations et les agglomérations
c'est un ensemble de quartiers qui sont
souvent éloignés les uns des autres il
faut les relier
et donc il faudrait qu'on ait les moyens
de relier les quartiers comme monsieur
pasqua veut donner les moyens aux
régions de se relier entre elles à plus
de pouvoir aux agglomérations plus de
décentralisation une meilleure gestion
des logements sociaux
les maires des grandes villes ne veulent
pas être les oubliés de charles pasqua
sinon ils ont prévenu plus sera la
fronde l'actualité à l'étranger
maintenant un cessez le feu semble avoir
été conclu au rwanda les témoins
présents à kigali la capitale affirme
que les armes se sont tues cet après
midi pour répondre aux accusations du
père henri blanchard vous l'entendiez
dans ce journal hier soir alain juppé le
ministre des affaires étrangères
s'engage ce soir si les massacres
continuent
la france dit il enverra des soldats et
respecté ou bien alors les massacres se
poursuit s'il se poursuivent nous ne
pouvons pas content je vais à tolérer
cette situation et la france dit qu'elle
est prête à ce moment-là a monté avec
d'autres avec ses partenaires européens
par exemple ou avec des africains
une opération pour sauver les
populations de quelle manière peu ton
monte
bien conscient que je ne vais pas vous
l'expliquer ici la décision de principe
pour la france de se dire prête à y
participer a été prise ce matin
évidemment les vols à vide bernard
kouchner l'ancien ministre de l'action
humanitaire est parti pour le rwanda
hier soir il veut essayer de renouer le
dialogue entre les différentes factions
plus aux normes est toujours en afrique
le soudan vit lui aussi un terrible
drame et ce dans l'indifférence la plus
complète depuis onze ans
valérie fournier pascal pons rentrer du
soudan où les victimes de la guerre et
de la famine se comptent par milliers
dès qu'un avion l'arc du ciel des sacs
de nourriture c'est en dessous
la course de la survie pour tous ces
enfants qui peuvent encore bouger courir
il se rue vers l'unique avion du
programme alimentaire mondial pour tout
le sud soudan ce sont les premiers sacs
de nourriture qui tombe du ciel depuis
plus de 10 jours alors il ramasse même
les miettes de l'aide internationale
ces milliers de grains de maïs échapper
des sacs qui ont fait éclater en touche
en somme les adultes eux se charge de
récupérer les sacs intacte pour les
redistribuer plus tard et pour ses
enfants c'est à chaque fois l'aubaine
rien ne doit se perdre et les mains va
puisse large balaie le sol et attrapes
l'acteur au passage afin de ne pas
laisser un seul de ces grains
qu'importe on fera le tri plus tard la
nourriture arrive mais pas en quantité
suffisante et surtout jamais quand il le
faut donc très difficile de donner une
nourriture équilibrée à cette population
traditionnellement nomades
l'urgence est donc de nourrir les plus
faibles priorité aux enfants
premières victimes de toutes les
familles et le constat est sévère
médecins sans frontières estime que le
taux de malnutrition surtout le
sud-soudan varie entre 30 et 45 % d'un
centre de nutrition pour enfant à
l'autre les mêmes chiffres
les mêmes images affaibli la fin devient
une maladie pour ses enfants et manger
devient une souffrance
les organisations non gouvernementales
leur donne ce que l'on appelle de l'uni
mix une bouillie énergétique trop rare
au sud soudan car là c'est par cette
guerre qui dure depuis onze ans les
donateurs ont réduit le budget de
laurède comme les états unis de 50% et
l'ambassadeur américain en visite sur
place avoue son impuissance donner
autant d'argent que l'année dernière
mais nous devons attendre et voir
le problème c'est qu'il ya des crises
qui se font la compétition entre elles
celle du rwanda en ce moment nous prive
de beaucoup de ressources et il ya la
situation en somalie qui coûte cher les
familles qui démarre en ethiopie et au
kenya
le problème c'est qu'il faudrait donner
à tout le monde au top 50 de
l'humanitaire le sud soudan ne fait plus
recette et donner des liens alors un
casse tête surtout quand le seul avion
usé à force de rotation tombe en panne
si aujourd'hui on n'est pas capable de
subvenir aux besoins minimums de ces
populations
cela veut dire que l'on va tomber dans
une situation catastrophique et je veux
dire l'aide qui sera demandée dès 6 mois
d'ici quatre mois d'ici trois mois sera
bien plus importante que ce que l'on
demande aujourd'hui avec une situation
qui est à la limite
chronique d'une famine annoncé et d'une
opération humanitaire à qui on a coupé
les ailes car pour une fois la
nourriture est là dans les hangars à la
frontière du sud-soudan prêt à sauver
deux millions de personnes dont 600
milles en situation d'extrême urgence en
algérie maintenant le changement de ton
des islamistes depuis sa prison le
numéro 2
du front islamique du salut ali belhadj
propose un débat télévisé au président
algérien monsieur zeroual jérôme le
changement de ton chez ali belhadj le
numéro deux du front islamique du salut
emprisonné à blida
lui qui en 91 enflammer les foules place
des martyrs à alger semble aujourd'hui
venir au dialogue
dans une lettre adressée au président
algérien le général zeroual
il lui propose un débat télévisé comme
préalable à ce dialogue
le dirigeant islamiste exige toujours la
libération de tous les prisonniers de
son mouvement mais il ne reprend pas
dans sa lettre l'habituel demande de
jugement des responsables de la
répression
l'objectif d'ali belhadj est sans doute
de casser l'image de terrorisme dans
laquelle le pouvoir veut enfermer tous
les islamistes de reprendre une parole
que le front islamique du salut s'est vu
confisquer dans tout le pays à sétif par
exemple où le siège du parti a été
transformées en commissariats de police
dialoguant avec tout le monde sans
exception
quelle est aujourd'hui l'audience des
islamistes dans la population algérienne
c'est la grande inconnue mais les
dirigeants du mouvement sont sans doute
persuadé qu'une apparition à la
télévision leur permettrait de
remobiliser leur électorat et demain
soir le magazine envoyé spécial sera
entièrement consacrée à l'algérie avec
notamment un reportage sur la vie
quotidienne dans une ville moyenne la
ville de sétif et un reportage sur les
difficultés des algériens qui sont
obligés de s'exiler en france
la psychose grandi dans la péninsule
coréenne la corée du nord vous le savez
est accusée par les occidentaux
notamment par les américains de vouloir
fabriquer sa propre arme atomique
la corée du sud voisine n'était en état
d' alerte maximale
tandis que l'ancien président américain
jimmy carter s'est rendu sur place pour
essayer de désamorcer la crise
gilles rabin
c'était il ya tout juste un an seoul un
grand magasin de corée du sud ont trait
à ses clients comment on vivait au nord
dans la corée communiste
la boucle est vite rythme
jamais triste de constater à quel point
le pousse et se creuse entre le nord et
le sud
il faudrait que notre pays soit réunifié
pour devenir plus équilibré et plus
puissant quand une moitié de corée a
plus de 50 ans de retard sur l'autre
moitié
tous rêvent de réunification est une
chimère aujourd'hui même les plus
timides espoirs d'ouverture se sont
évanouis séoul qui est à portée des
canons du nord vital heures d exercice
de défense passive dans la crainte de la
guerre le prix des denrées de base a
doublé on s'arrache les masques à gaz et
les trousses médicales de première
urgence au nord comme au sud
on ne crois pas beaucoup à la médiation
tentée par l'ancien président américain
jimmy carter qui veut rester optimiste
la corée du nord refuse-t-elle toute
inspection internationale parce qu'elle
possède vraiment la bombe atomique ou au
contraire parce qu'elle ne la possèdent
pas escalade ou bluff
où peut mener cette partie de poker
menteur la zone démilitarisée qui sépare
les deux corées a été fermé retour à la
guerre froide sur le dernier rideau de
fer de la planète
on ne passe pas restons à l'étranger
avec une image peu banale maintenant le
numéro un cubain fidel castro a troqué
son uniforme vert-olive vous allez le
voir pour un costume civil à l'occasion
d'un sommet ibéro américains en colombie
changements de costumes mes permanences
du discours anti américain alors qu'à la
havane des dizaines de candidats au
départ continuent de se réfugier dans
les ambassades
israël et le vatican vont échanger des
représentants spéciaux autrement dit des
ambassadeurs des relations diplomatiques
complètes ont été établis aujourd'hui et
puis en italie la police a réalisé ce
matin l'un des plus gros coup de filet
anti mafia de ces dernières années dans
le nord du pays
michel field la justice italienne avait
lancé par moins de 370 mandat d'arrêt
toute la nuit
toute la matinée en lombardie dont le
nord du pays
deux mille policiers sont passés à
l'acte enchaînant cinq cents
perquisitions et des 10
d'interpellations parmi les suspects
figuraient des carabiniers des membres
de la police financière mais aussi des
personnages déjà incarcéré pour crime
trafic d'armes ou de stupéfiants
il aura fallu à la justice italienne des
mois d'enquêté les révélations de
plusieurs repentis pour arriver à
reconstituer une partie de
l'organigramme de cosa nostra la mafia
sicilienne et de la 'ndrangheta la mafia
calabraise en croire le ministre de
l'intérieur ce qui est aujourd'hui
présenté comme le plus vaste coup de
filet lancé en italie depuis 10 ans a
permis de décapiter entièrement
l'organisation de la mafia calabraise
mouloudji marcel de son prénom a déserté
la nuit dernière les faubourgs parisiens
qui l'avait vu naître il ya 71 ans
mouloudji laissera à ses contemporains
des chansons populaires qui lui
ressemble et ans et aux plus jeunes
générations l'exemple d'un homme resté
fidèle toute sa vie à ses propres
convictions
évocation avec georges de meyst sur le
corsage blanc
ce matin en gare
j'avais
la goutte de sang qui faisait comme un
petit coquelicot mon âme tout petit mon
logis cette graine d'ananar comme il
aimait à sa plaie était un tendre un
poète un humoriste en 52 le cinéma on
avait fait une vedette dans le film
d'andré cayatte nous sommes tous des
assassins mouloudji incarnait un
personnage de tueur déstabilisé par la
guerre très éloigné de sa propre nature
il a toujours gardé une espèce
d'adolescence il avait cette silhouette
comme sa mince et je crois que ça fait
partie d'une époque où on faisait
souvent les choses plus pour le plaisir
que pour la gloire ou où la carrière où
l'argent en tout cas l'argent n'est
sûrement pas une des préoccupations
majeures de mouloudji et sa carrière non
plus
je pense qu'il faisait les choses qu'il
avait envie de faire au moment où il
avait envie de les faire vroum jeu je
fais de temps de me tuer ou deux fois ça
a très bien marché puis après je suis
retombé dans la figuration avait pu
et puis bon dieu ça mais je ne peux pas
moi je parle de la république oui ben
oui pour moi c'est la même chose
les jours heureux où nous étions amis ni
en ce temps là la plus belle
et le soleil
plus brûlante aujourd'hui les feuilles
mortes se ramassent pas la tête tu vois
je n'ai pas oublié
les souvenirs et les regrets
littérature et peinture sur les
dernières passion de sa vie ses tableaux
lui ressembler sensible quotidien
c'était un touche à tout sans avoir
l'air d'y toucher j'expose tu peu
partout surtout en banlieue un peu
partout mais pas dans un circuit
professionnel
je veux pas rentrer là dedans parce que
c'est pas parce que je me suis gardé ma
terre un jour ça ira
on se rencontre va quelque part non pour
que tout est art le vase rab nouvelle
qu'un gars de rang
et nous sourire on est là m'attends à un
oubli avait grandi dans le saint germain
des prés de l'après-guerre cet
après-midi carole comment et philippe
luzzi ont rendu visite
alain viande le frère de boris vian dont
le fameux déserteurs avaient été
interprétés par mouloudji alain via ans
vit toujours à saint germain des prés et
ils se racontent une petite rue au coeur
de saint germain des prés le quartier
fétiche d'alain vian depuis presque
toujours il y tient encore une petite
boutique remplie d'anciens instruments
mais aussi de quelques livres parlent de
son copain mouloudji
l'atmosphère de l'époque c'est une
atmosphère absolument libératoire où
tout le monde s'adore en 80 bouge on ne
sait pas ce que c'est qu'une bagarre le
petit groupe faisait toutes les boîtes
du quartier entre 10 heures du soir et 6
heures du matin on faisait un peu la
tournée des des petits grands ducs avec
nos faibles moyens parce que c'était
tout à fait tout le monde était
affreusement fauché à l'époque
e
le déserteur pour moi c'est une partie
de la vie du frère et c'est aussi une
chanson qui correspond chez les jeunes
un refus absolu de se battre de se
rebattre donc pour moi c'est une chanson
tout à fait d'actualité
avec mouloudji c'est aussi une partie de
saint germain des prés qui disparaît
aujourd'hui une autre légende dans un
autre genre retracé sur les écrans
français celle des beatles le film sorti
aujourd'hui s'appelle backbeat il
raconte l'histoire d'un cinquième homme
en effet je vous l'apprends peut-être au
début de leur carrière les beatles
étaient cinq
reportage de pascal deschamps et
frédéric basket on a oublié son nom son
visage dans l'ombre de john lennon ou de
paul mccartney tu voir sa griffe
il était avec le groupe lorsqu'un jour
de mai 1960 les silver beetles les
scarabées d'argent c'était leur nom à
l'époque quitter liverpool pour hambourg
leur premier contrat en poche pendant
quelques mois les enfants terribles de
liverpool vont enflammer les nuits de
hambourg le film raconte les premiers
pas du groupe de rock le plus célèbre du
monde
aidez moi j'ai vraiment essayé très émue
par l'histoire de stewart n'avait jamais
entendu parler de lui
comme la plupart des jeunes américains
je pensais que le cinquième beatles
étaient pinaise leur premier batteur et
on ne connaît pas la légende de ce
qu'ils voient qu'on ne connaît pas leurs
débuts on a tendance à croire que les
people sont arrivés comme ça d'un seul
ou avec un tube love me do alors qu'au
début il ya vraiment une histoire
intéressante
stuart sutcliffe provocateur et torturé
n'aura jamais vraiment pris la musique
au sérieux et c'est par amitié pour son
copain d'enfance lennon qu'il abandonne
sa passion première la peinture
l'histoire était intéressante parce que
d'un côté c'est marrant de voir ce qui
s'est passé dans les premiers mois de la
carrière d'un groupe célèbre nous on
sait ce qui s'est passé après mais on ne
le savait pas encore mais d'un autre
côté ce qui leur arrive dans ce film
aurait pu arriver à n'importe qui
si on meurt d'une hémorragie cérébrale à
22 ans quelques mois seulement après
avoir quitté le groupe qui sait s'il
était resté 6 aux côtés de l'éthique
billets des jude le groupe n'aurait pas
compter d'autres tubes
saisi par ses visions
merci beaucoup
du cinéma à la télévision au mois de
septembre france 2 vous proposera une
série de téléfilms sur la vie dans un
lycée le titre de cette série madame le
proviseur est inspiré des livres de
marguerite gensbittel proviseur du
célèbre lycée fénelon à paris
marie-hélène bono et jean yves dusserre
ont rencontré le proviseur et la
comédienne danièle delorme
mais au fait qu'est-ce qu'un proviseur
de nos jours un proviseur c'est une
espèce d'individus tous toutes
spécialités confondues c'est à dire
n'ayant aucune là pour faire que
l'enfant et l'école puis se rencontrer
sans qu'ils aient trop d'étincelles et
sans qu'ils aient trop de misère et de
souffrance pour l'enfant a endossé sa
livrée d'écoliers rencontre au lycée
molière à paris entre l'actrice et le
proviseur l'une jouant le rôle de
l'autre danièle delorme et valentine un
personnage inspiré des oeuvres de
marguerite gensbittel l'actrice ne
demande pas particulièrement des conseil
à madame le proviseur
simplement elles parlent de leur métier
respectif qu'il était bon aussi qu'on se
connaissent bien mais pas trop parce que
je pense qu'il ya une liberté tout à
fait tout à fait respectable et respecté
de l'actrice dans un rôle et que pour ce
rôle là comme pour les autres elle a
droit à son art et à sa liberté
imprescriptible et l'actrice que
pense-t-elle de son modèle et je suis
impressionné en même pas
vrai par un éclat de rire à chaque fois
je vous à rencontrer ça que j'ai été
très contente de vous rencontrer la dame
aux prises l'as sur le métier parce que
ce que vous m'avez posé comme question
qui finit pas de me les poser du moteur
josé pinheiro réalise téléfilm trois
fois 90 minutes
il met en scène le milieu scolaire
chacun d'entre nous a des souvenirs
d'école
le personnage principal n'est plus
l'instit mais le proviseur valentine
hugo dans chaque épisode est là une
affaire à résoudre celui là je le vois
trop bizarre quand il s'appelle jean les
brûleurs à ranger les vélos
le tournage se termine le lycée molière
rebaptisé lycée belgrand le premier
numéro de madame le proviseur sera
diffusé sur france 2 à la rentrée
rendez vous est pris avant d'ouvrir une
page sportive amateur de bons vins
réjouissez-vous le sommelier nouveau est
arrivé
tous les deux ans est décerné le titre
de meilleur sommelier de france et cette
année le cru est bourguignon
il s'appelle lionel lecomte invitation à
la dégustation avec pascal golomer et
philippe mantois 6
c'est l'histoire d'une passion passion
pour le vin et ses mystères passion pour
un métier d'abord et pour la compétition
aussi le meilleur c'est lui lionel le
conte se meulier chez bernard loiseau
depuis 88 un titre obtenu après une
ultime confrontation à trois concurrents
avec à midi l'épreuve du service chacun
s'occupe une table tout simplement
mais trois juges sont là pour les
observer noter leurs faits et gestes
leurs erreurs leurs qualités et d'abord
la sûreté prendre confiance le
rapidement au bout de quelques secondes
et les chars autour de ses clients est
dans son service et faire fraction que
c'est à ton tour et faire ce qu'ils font
chaque jour dans l'établissement mais
l'épreuve reine décisives et impitoyable
c'est la dégustation à l'aveuglé de vins
un apéritif unique heures une eau de vie
qu'il faut décrire reconnaître lorsque
cela est possible
le tout en moins de 15 minutes alors un
petit peu d'infusion pour le côté
végétal on a le tilleul on a un petit
côté mentaux les bonne densité de
matière par contre on peut noter quand
même une acidité un petit peu en retrait
où 78 peut-être pour la profondeur de
couleurs sont 19 sourire on devient un
peu plus clair cabernet merlot disons
cabernet merlot lionel le compte n'a pas
reconnu la côte rôtie 86 mais une bonne
description peut faire la différence
la bonne réponse elle tient parfois à si
peu de choses dont 87 connaissant les
cépages les régions les terroirs
on arrive par élimination parfois à
retrouver des dégâts ou bien si on a
beaucoup beaucoup d'expérience et qu'on
a goûté c'est vers là on peut arriver à
retrouver parce qu'il ya d'instinct est
quelque chose qui est qui déclenche on
dit qu'un ca c c
c'est un arôme que je reconnais que dans
ce vent se vent là et boum donc là on
considérait jeu directement et madame
n'a pas fini de s'angoisser en décembre
c'est la finale internationale que
lionel lecomte devra discuter une courte
passe de sportive pour dire qu'au
tournoi sur gazon de halle en allemagne
un tournoi qui sert de répétition avant
le tournoi de wimbledon
henri leconte qui n'est jamais aussi à
l'aise sur l'herbe à éliminer cet après
midi le russe andreï volkov en deux
manches très sèches 6 0 6 1 en revanche
l'autre français cédric pioline a lui
été battu
voici la balle de match
et puis à 48 heures de l'ouverture de la
coupe du monde aux états unis les
américains sont sceptiques leur équipe
nationale sera t elle capable de tenir
la dragée haute aux vedettes du football
mondial les réponses de yann là c'est en
mars 91 le beau ramon une lutte tu mets
le pied en californie à mission viejo
c'est ici qu'il bâtit ce camp
d'entraînement pour préparer l'équipe
américaine à la coupe du monde aura srb
parle cinq langues
il se sent donc bien au milieu de ses
joueurs américains aux origines diverses
lexique n irlandaise grecque ou
italienne à michel verreault la bonne
ambiance a toujours été de rigueur ça je
pense que c'est important
normalement je devrais être consciente
la coupe du monde c'est une compétition
hautement importante qu'elle suscite
l'intérêt du monde entier
finalement ça reste un match de football
à 11 contre 11 avec un arbre alors on
doit se faire plaisir et sur plaisir
c'est le meilleur moyen de ne pas jeter
ses précieuses en trois ans l'équipe
américaine a multiplié les matches
internationaux environ 80
le meilleur souvenir cette victoire 2-0
l'an passé sur l'angleterre un exploit
qui n'a pas eu de véritable
retentissement aux états unis car en
fait des petits gars sont loin mais
alors très loin d'être des stars dans
leur pays
heureusement ils ont leurs supporters
des supporters qui apprécient le style
de jeu de cette équipe
on y retrouve l'engagement physique
anglo saxons et la touche technique
latine avec un brin de décontraction à
l'américaine bord a su donner confiance
à cette équipe comme il avait su le
faire avec le mexique en 86 et le costa
rica en 90 minutes une vitre a toujours
dirigé l'équipe surprise de la coupe du
monde
c'est pour ça qu'on le surnomme le
magicien et vous allez voir en 94
le magicien aux la début de la coupe du
monde donc vendredi dans un instant les
prévisions météo de sophie davant il va
faire de plus en plus chaud est de plus
en plus beau sur la france mais si c'est
possible
à 20h50 un téléfilm américain la vie en
marche le dernier journal aux environs
de minuit demain matin télé matin dès
6h30 à 7h50 pour les 4 vérités gérard
leclerc recevra madame marie claire
mendès-france je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée merci beaucoup